this is the summer of Barbie and cottage
cheese so let's smash them together and
make the most badass pink protein packed
breakfast on this app let's call it the
Kennedy breakfast so cool step one
cottage cheese loaded with protein step
two we got some cooked beets a little
bit of Mascarpone cheese for some extra
creaminess and richness
and we puree now that's pink we got some
toasted sourdough gonna smear all that
pink cheesy sweet protein packed spread
on top top it off with some fresh
strawberries crushed pistachios a little
fresh thyme and a drizzle of honey
finish with a little flaky salt and that
my friends is definitely enough we got
protein fiber and healthy fats and most
importantly it's pink I promise you you
and your Ken are gonna love it